reality wedding yes we've got up I do
and I don't situation on Netflix hit
dating show love is life this premise is
crazy can couples fall in love without
actually seeing each other and then
getting married we've got everything you
need to know about America's new dating
obsession here you will choose someone
to marry
without ever seeing them will you marry
me hiren and Lauren were the first
couple to fall in love they spent 10
days talking before he popped the
question everyone sees Lauren she's
breathtaking by myself closing my eyes
when we're talking to kind of focus in
on what she's saying instead of getting
distracted by her tonight
we find out which of the couples say I
do it's a secret Netflix has been
keeping for over a year
internet sleuths are onto it and
tracking down all these clues where we
similarities and our pictures poor
secrets about the show the longest dates
and the pods lasted for hours how do you
see anything no no one else was in the
pod besides the singles hidden robotic
cameras captured all the action and all
the daters were from the Atlanta area so
were there any run-ins before the show
started I'm asked with one of the girls
on the other side on one of the dating
apps ooh I think it might have been
Jeezy
thirty people actually tried the
experiments we saw six couples get
engaged but there were actually more
proposals so after getting engaged to
Danielle the leads came in to our rooms
and talked to us individually and just
explained listen we just didn't realize
that this was going to be so successful
we didn't know that so many couples were
gonna get engaged and we kind of had to
just pick which ones we thought were
gonna go all the way fan-favorite Rory
who viewers only saw playing therapists
didn't stay engaged long she actually
ended up having feelings for other guy
on the show and ended up dating him for
a little bit post show as well and there
was a little bit of a love triangle
going on there but back to the finale
each couple was given a wedding budget
and anything over had to come from their
own pockets which puts me at least like
four dollars budget and the engagement
rings were provided Wow I picked the
perfect one because is simple with a big
rock now tomorrow we're gonna have more
interviews with the love is blind
couples ahead of next week's big reunion
only et is exclusively behind the scenes
and we'll have that for you on Monday
[Music]